There was a period and it's been interesting to see the pendulum swing somewhat.
So Silicon Valley could do no wrong for a long time.
Where do you see is because they're just like, Oh, you're like the innovators,
you're the super value creators and you're rich as.
And you donate to my campaign. So let's just like,
leave you the heck alone and just sing your praises every chance we get. Uh,
and then that pendulum has swung because of, uh, like, uh,
Facebook screwing, some things up and, uh, and, and some other problems. Uh,
so now everyone's starting to turn on a turn towards them and be like,
wait a minute. Like, you know,
is this really been like cool that Amazon is, you know, like,
uh, so one of the things that I think Amazon did wrong there, you know,
a bunch of things, but like there's diapers.com where they just lost
money on diapers for a while, just like forced diapers.com to sell to them.
Like Amazon did that sort of thing.
Just because I don't, I know about that story, correct me if I'm wrong.
So they basically like diapers.com was a popular website.
They're selling lots of diapers, Amazon lowered their price. And below that,
to the point where they were losing money, just to put them out of business,
and then they raised their prices back up when they go on, they're not cool now.
So they go out of business. It was like, they come to diapers.com and be like,
Hey guys, you guys are awesome. How are we buying? And then diapers.com is like,
no. And then Amazon's like, Oh, we'll see about that.
So then they lowered prices to a point where diapers.com was like hemorrhaging
money. And then they were like, okay, I guess we will sell to you now.
And then it was on it's like, that's what I thought.
And then as soon as they buy them, then the prices go back up.
That's how that should be. Is that illegal? Um, that is illegal. Yes.
Uh, or it's illegal in the, in the sense that it's, uh,
anti-competitive behavior it's against the antitrust law. Um, so,
so that sort of thing has been coming out. Now, if something similar with,
and this was like, to me,
the biggest nonsense was when Mark Zuckerberg was asked, like, Hey,
um, the people,
the founders of Instagram are worried that if they didn't sell to you,
that you were going to try and, uh, uh,
put them out of business and now compete with them are going to destroy mode,
I think was the term destroy mode. And then Mark was like,
no, I never would have done that. And then like,
we all know it's like if Instagram had sold a to Facebook,
you would know there would have been a free kid,
like Instagram clone out like that. Uh, and so,
so this is officially, you know,
it violates anti-trust law to, to do certain anti-competitive things, uh,
like that. But the, the reality is like, of course, that, you know,
if you're in that industry,
like you're going to do everything you can to try and crush anyone who could
potentially end up taking your business. I think you have to assume.
There's a lot of that going on. We don't know of with, I mean,
any company that gets to be that big, you're looking at the Microsofts.
You're looking at the Amazon, you're looking at the Facebooks. I mean,
you can't, I mean, correct me if I'm wrong,
can you get to be that big of a company without antitrust
violations.
Antica, without some competitive behavior, it would be difficult.
And the thing that most people don't realize now,
and this is one reason why I think universal basic income so vital among others
is that some of these companies have essentially just like left orbit in terms
of business physics. Like you think, okay, like I'm a company I need to like,
you know, be efficient and treat my workers well, and like sell,
sell things that are profit. There's some companies that at this point,
I'm just like, like I'm worth a trillion dollars.
I don't even need to make money. Nothing matters. Like, what's that,
you're like a cool startup. Like,
I can buy you for $400 million and everyone's rich and I don't even care. Like,
they're just so
big that like that, that not like nothing applies.
I think Tim O'Reilly called it like super money. It's like,
at some point you just get super money and then like nothing matters.
And then we still try and pretend.
And what was funny is when they got brought into Congress, like they pretend to,
it's like, Oh, we started into this crappy company. They're like, they, they,
they it's like freaking at this point,
they're almost like countries on to themselves.
They're just so staggeringly, enormously wealthy.
And they have now at this point,
their stock market valuations are propped up in so many ways that
they can almost do no wrong. Uh,
and in that environment,
they're just going to keep sucking up more and more value. Like the,
the thing I kept saying to folks on the trail was like, look,
Amazon is worth a trillion bucks, paid zero in taxes,
soaking up $20 billion a year in commerce, closing 30% of your stores and malls.
And that was pretty crisis. It's like, you know, these things like a black hole.
So let's just skip it, just suck more and more about value in,
and we're not going to see anything coming out. Um, and you think it's like, Oh,
it's because they're like out competing at some point they just left orbit.
And it, and the funny thing about Amazon is like,
there've been periods in his past where it didn't even make money,
but at this point you look at it and being like,
like there was a Walmart executive who complained to me, he said,
how can you compete against a company that doesn't even need to make money?
And this was Walmart,
which is sort of ironic because Walmart honestly like crushed every like mom and
pop retailer. And it's complaining.
About Amazon. It's beautiful.
But yeah, like I joked with the Walmart folks. It's like,
they were like the tanks that came to American communities around the country
just like ran over every mom and pop. And then there were like, we did it,
we conquered America. And then Amazon's like a spaceship,
like hovering over them. It's like,
we don't need to obey the laws of gravity anymore. It's like,
what do we do? And then you have our government over here. And like,
they're just like, you know, the government doesn't understand what is going on.
And just looking up being like, yeah, like Amazon's a company. Like any other
that that's like the [inaudible] yeah. They have their own. I mean,
if you look at what's going on with Amazon, like Jeff Bezos is so rich,
he bought the Washington post with essentially like pocket change from his
couch. Like, you know, like the Washington post is a very,
very influential publication.
That happens to be like the main news source in our nation's Capitol. Like,
do you think that, you know, literally, and,
and he has been relatively hands-off like he has, he doesn't go in and be like,
write about this, write about that. But it is,
it's telling it's that like Amazon up here, Jeff Bezos, like, you know,
a peer and then like, you know,
our nation's major media,
like news source for our legislators was like down here. And he was like, yeah,
like, sure. It's like,
it's like took a couple of hundred million out of the couch. It does. I mean,
he's worth at this point, hundreds of billions anyway. Sorry.
That was fascinating. And I think it really it's terrifying.
I think that analogy of it's like Walmart came in with the tanks and,
but they weren't thinking big enough.
And Amazon came in with the UFO spaceship and just zapped them.
I kept thinking about the video games you play when you're like you keep
grading and you replay.
Again with all the upgrades. Yeah. Just way stronger. Every time.
Red big is one. I want to wrap this story because it's, to me,
it was interesting. So the founder,
one of the founders of diapers.com was a guy named Mark lore.
So then Amazon crushes, diapers.com absorbs them. Mark.
Laura becomes rich, but he's mad at Amazon.
So he comes back for revenge years later and starts
jet.com raises. I think he raised like,
like $500 million,
a billion dollars being like we are going to out-compete Amazon.
And e-commerce like, he's like, I have found the way. And so
it's so he got all of these investors to pilot, the jet.com
and@jet.com was like spending. Do you remember jet.com
jet dot? Got they had, I think their color,
it was purple had like Jed that some smiling anyway.
So jet.com spends hundreds of millions trying to fight it out with Amazon and
e-commerce and then Walmart buys jet.com as a way
to try and make themselves competitive on Amazon in
e-commerce. So, so that's like the, how it all fit together. It's like Mark,
Laura came back for revenge and then ended up like getting absorbed by Walmart
in a relatively few tile attempt to try and bring down the spaceship.
So weird. Why? Ah, that's so funny.
I guess it never happened. I mean, Walmart failed to, to make it competitive.
It sounds like.
Yeah. I don't think it's worked out being like, sure. I'll that again?
Dot com and Walmart had to do something.
Let's see if jet.com is still no, it just,
it literally redirected to walmart.com. Yeah.
I think they paid a billion dollars for jet.com. Like if you could look,
look up that that.
Were they just thinking like, look, we can't deal with another one of these.
Okay.
I just want, it was,
it was literally to try and bring on Marc lore to be like the Amazon killer.
Cause if there was like any human that represented the diapers guy.
Yeah. Like the David Day, I was like a lie. There was this guy, Mark lore.
And he had a chip on his shoulder because he was like, I'm back, uh,
back you, you destroyed my diapers.com a spaceship.
And now we're back with like jet.com. And anyway,
I found that story really interesting in large
part,
because Mark was so compelling that he raised hundreds of millions of dollars,
uh, for an e-commerce company to try and rival Amazon.
And I thought that was like the most amazing act of salesmanship I had ever
heard. I was like, wow, this guy must be the most convincing dude.
Well, they all, they all got, they all made money. It sounds like by the,
by the end of it, except Walmart.
I think that's correct. Yeah. Yeah, that's correct.
But I think it really underlies this issue of how can we possibly govern
in the face of such super money if our regulators and our
elected officials don't even understand what they're looking at,
like their understanding of what is going on at a company like Amazon is so
terrestrial. If we're talking, if they're in outer space, these guys are,
you know, all of.
Every week I go on and on now I find it. I find more and more creepy stuff.
Like at first they just had a few like Amazon basic items.
Now it's like every product that you look up,
they already have an Amazon brand that makes it it's amazing. I just,
I don't know. It creeps me out every time.
For weird. They have, they have their own brand for literally as my Newt,
as like a pen, a lighter to as big as like a.
Well, any closing thing, you would look up.
Shopping products, EV everything, they have it.
They they're a machine.
So what they do is they have this marketplace and then they have this giant data
dashboard. They figure out as soon as like something's selling of this turn low,
right. They're like they, they go and make it.
And so you have these horror stories of this company being like, you know,
I sold on Amazon and I was happy until one day, like, you know, the,
their competitor came and I couldn't get into the search listings and now I am
dead. And like, they they're this giant,
uh, money machine that just comes in. And like,
it's a combination of like endless resources and endless access to us
and our needs and then endless data, uh, like there's no, there,
there is no real competition. Um, there there's something like,
there's something that has changed about capitalism. Um, and,
and the problem is that we pretend it's still like the seventies and eighties
like that there is like a genuine market between firms when you have these,
uh, these companies that have just reached unprecedented scale size
resources. Uh,
and it's being facilitated by this new version of, uh,
of the markets where there are certain companies that just everyone's going to
pile into because they're absorbing more and more of the
economy. It's like, you, you look up and just, you know, you ask anyone.
It's like, um, you know, like, like Amazon, Apple,
Facebook, Google would be the big ones where you just look up and being like,
Hey, you know, if you close your eyes and open them 10 years from now, like,
do you think those companies will still be, um, kicking and dominating?
Like the answer is yes. In the less, uh,
in less the government were to change something for one of those companies. Um,
and you're starting to see glimmers of that possibility,
uh, because people are starting to recognize some of the extremes. Um,
I may be part of this conversation moving forward too.
Oh, Jeff Bezos just found his biggest worst enemy.
It's not hard floor. Jeff.
You've been looking in the wrong place at the wrong. Okay.
And closing, I want to ask you one final question.
You have endorsed, uh, Joe Biden.
Tell me why do you think Joe Biden will make a better president than Donald
Trump?
Joe Biden would make a better president of the Donald Trump on many,
many levels, but the things I love about Joe, number one,
he's actually a good dude who cares about people and wants,
wants to do right by people. Number two is he's really not very ideological.
He's more of like a pragmatist where he's like, what are we going to do? Um,
and as part of his pregnant, TISM, he's a consensus seeker.
He tries to figure out what the folks around him think is the right approach.
And he's not going to be someone and being like, no, screw you. Like,
I'm sure like the way to go. And it's not what you're saying. Like,
he'll actually be like, well, if people think that this is the way to go,
like I'm into it. And then the third thing, uh, is, was something I said,
um, at that convention,
which is that Joe has this quality where anything he says becomes the new
reasonable. Um,
like he came out with a $2 trillion green energy proposal that could have
been straight out of the Bernie or arc like a playbook.
And if one of them had said it, people would have been like, Oh, like, you know,
uh, aggressive pie in the sky. But then Joe says it and was like, yeah,
that's cool.
That you can.
That, that if Joe gets on board with something or champions,
and then all a sudden it becomes the new mainstream.
And so you have to ask yourself, it's like, okay,
maybe I just agree with John some stuff, but it's like, what,
what's my preferred path, trying to convince Joe, that this is a good idea,
or try and convince Donald Trump that he should, you know,
like adopt an incomplete, completely different approach to governance. Uh,
and I mean, that, that to me is a no brainer.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.